so we are
slightly short of
a quorum I think there's no reason that
we can't have meaningful discussion
given that we are a subcommittee rather
than a full committee
and
um I'm going to begin not by asking the
clerk to call the role but by calling
the role myself in as much and insofar
as I know who's on the committee and the
clerk May in fact not so figure it out
and so um in and then I'll have a
preparatory comment to make about
today's proceedings so calling the role
not present representative Merchant
representative Cannon president
representative Edwards yes
representative salloway
president I believe that is now we do
have some outside I think he named seven
people
uh did you mean to mention uh Dr Errol
maholland yes and he is not present but
it's difficult for him to be present uh
in that he is a clinician and I have
arranged to meet with him uh after this
meeting at his uh hospital to go over
the proceedings of so I'm just curious
because we have four of the seven
legislative members I wonder if that
constitutes a quorum since he's not a
legislator
if we hit four of seven then we have a
simple majority in a form
Catholic
represents always chair and with
committee's Indulgence understanding
that I obviously worked for an executive
branch agency not legislative but just
to be helpful that represent Mark
Pearson did appoint eight members to
serve on the committee uh represent
Betty gay might have been the additional
one I was trying to follow your um your
so that would be your number eight for
that so you under simple rules of a
committee Quorum that would be five of
the eight would constitute a quorum so
so I have an exception that I'm flying
by it since you're an expert the eighth
person is a civilian not a legislator
the civilian is not here so the seven
legislators appointed to the
eight-person committee four of them are
here so four of seven legislators to me
would still be a form
I would not disagree with your
interpretation uh representative Edwards
on on that issue but if you're a
complete purist it is ape were appointed
to that so unless I I'm
respectfully it's um it's not even my
place to make this it's just trying to
be helpful thank you thank you Mr chair
uh please representative Woods uh
doesn't make a difference whether it's a
committee
or a
um a commission commissioner uh I but I
mean um but it falls into that category
that's very interesting
um does that change the flavor at all in
terms of consideration okay I'm seeing a
right to left a wiggle rather than up
again respectively for the record John
Williams director of legislative affairs
and because you are constituted by
virtue of your parent committee the HHS
ever say committee and there were eight
members appointed that committee the
same rules under Quorum requirements
right to know all those would still
apply to this subcommittee I would say
though if the issue here is being able
to proceed with less than a form you can
absolutely do that to hold a meeting you
just can't take any official action
either on minutes or specifically
emotions my understanding is that
there's going to be an intention to
reconvene perhaps for a short meeting to
take up the final recommendations
reported this committee at that time it
would be necessary to having a quorum to
be able to vote on that but for today's
purposes you can do just about
everything else you would like to do
with the exception of actually taking
official actions um on on matters I hope
that's helpful
thank you very
um I can only keep my fingers crossed
that
um somebody else will show up I'm hoping
that representative Merchant or gay will
appear
um
you have before you I believe everybody
has copies of the minutes of the meeting
of October 3rd
I would like to take a moment to
indicate that these minutes are
exceptionally complete and detailed uh
as per the efforts of uh councilor
Williams I'm very grateful to him I took
my own minutes I've merged my
observations with his and I think you
have a pretty complex complete set of
the minutes that's terribly important
for the record in that I believe that
the uh
girl I don't want to call it testimony
the observations posited by
representative woods and representative
Merchant at our last meeting were simply
seminal in calling for
um a refocus of our deliberations on
this subcommittee
um
and I am indebted to representative
Woods who was able to re-establish our
scientific basis for evaluating clinical
interventions as the basis on which to
make a decision with regard to policy
and I'd like to propose later in this
meeting which it appears will be a brief
meeting I would like to propose a draft
resolution which if we don't have a
quorum we won't be able to vote on but
for an informational purposes I will
pass that around and we can discuss
whether this is uh appropriate for the
direction of the committee
prior that I would like to invite Peg
Clifford to address this subcommittee
I'll ask her to introduce herself I
would do to an inadequate job I think
but simply to say that she comes to us
from the DHHS office of Medicaid it
specializes in pharmacologic issues
within Medicaid and I hope that she will
introduce herself tell us a little bit
about her background and talk to us a
little bit about what the Medicaid
related issues are with regard to
Precision medicine and other medical
Technologies
Miss Clifford
aye thank you yeah my name is Margaret
Clifford I go by Peg I'm a licensed
pharmacist in the state of New Hampshire
and I am the pharmacy director for New
Hampshire Medicaid so in that role I
review policies and procedures for the
coverage of medication and we have to
follow
um
federal law and requirements to the
coverage of medicine medications so when
it comes to Precision medicine
the department does not have a um a
position on that right now but we do
consider each individual request for
coverage on an individual case-by-case
basis and we look at whether or not the
treatment is deemed medically necessary
and that's done with Pharmacists and
Physicians
the trading provider along with the
director
the medical director for Medicaid is
part of those decisions on the
case-by-case coverage
as far as coverage of individual drugs
there's a requirement under federal law
that if the manufacturer participates
with the federal drug rebate program
State Medicaid programs are required to
cover that medication but we can put
coverage guidelines around it which we
do through prior authorization so
um
we can look at the individual drug come
up with criteria that fits and put the
prior authorization in place around that
hello
are you
questions
so I I don't know if that's on your
website somewhere about the you know
on the individual products with the
offensive
yeah
um I'm not sure if it's specifically on
the website we do have a drug lookup
tool on our website under the DHHS
pharmacy program Medicaid pharmacy
program you can click on the link for
drug coverage and you can type in the
name of the drug and it will tell you
um whether or not the drug is covered
whether or not it needs prior
authorization and
um
so the the DHHS website has the link for
both the FIFA service program in each
if I may
the critical issue for us is whether
a drug is federally approved
and do we need prior authors
authorization
to fund the prescription of a drug or a
diagnostic procedure
Etc oh that's out of your bailiwick I
understand that
so you need Federal approval prior
author authorization and
um
I'm going to ask Miss Clifford if you
will give us a word about uh the
presence of biomarkers as part of the
prior approval process
okay so
um
the biomarkers I don't know a whole lot
about it I know a little bit about it
there are certain of the newer high cost
um Precision drugs if you will that are
targeted to an individual
that um
you would need to make sure that they
have the diagnosis and if there are
certain genes required to be present to
make sure that they have that individual
biomarker in order for the treatment to
have a potential to work and
um
there's a you know I don't know
um because we're speaking in general I
can't say the defectiveness of the
treatment because those are all
individual
and
do I assume
that in the search for appropriate
biomarkers it for a Medicaid patient it
would be Medicaid that would pay for the
screening to determine if the biomarkers
are present yes
can you give us any examples
of what the costs might be of the
diagnostic procedure to identify
biomarkers and then later the
appropriate
pharmacologic interventions
I don't have those costs available right
now
um I would have to look at because those
come in on a medical claim and my focus
is on Pharmacy claims but that's
something that we could look at and get
back to you with
okay what about the cost of
interventions for precision medicine
do you have any sense of what some of
those drug interventions might cause
again you know it's it's based on the
diagnosis and and what the treatment is
and so I'm more familiar with the drugs
that come through on the pharmacy side
as opposed to the medical side but I do
I do know that
um when drugs are administered through
an outpatient or hospital we have to
make sure those codes are up in the
system we get notification and and make
sure we have those codes set to either
pay or pay on review you know so some
some codes can suspend
um so that we have that review to make
sure determine the medical necessity and
others are set to pay and I talked about
prior authorization but that doesn't
mean that every drug out there requires
a prior authorization there's you know
some drugs do but not all
as you assess a protocol
or a drug and let us say and I
understand that you personally in your
office are not responsible for
um Diagnostics
you're responsible only for drug
interventions as a pharmacist hitting up
that part of DHHS
um is one of the criteria for
authorization
the apparent effectiveness of the drug
intervention
um
I'm not sure on on that I think uh so
Medicaid is required to have a drug
utilization review board which we have
um and that's made up of uh three
Physicians and three pharmacists that
are licensed here in New Hampshire
and we bring criteria to them for
specific medications
they review and then
um we also Medicaid also has a contract
with an independent medical review
contractor that has specialists in
different fields so we can ask them to
take a look our medical director also
takes a look and there is public input
in the dur process when we're reviewing
criteria for medications so the
manufacturers or Physicians anyone from
the public can speak to a drug that we
are reviewing
um those meetings happen about twice a
year
as you go through
the daily medical claims that come
across your desk
do you have a sense of the range of
effectiveness
for the drugs that we wind up
prescribing under Medicaid
you know between what and what
is what we are likely to see in terms of
varies based on the drug class and the
and the diagnosis like for example we
can talk about hepatitis C there are
treatments for Hepatitis C that are
highly effective
um the treatments for Hepatitis C
initially had a very
um high price associated with them that
price has come down considerably over
the last few years so initially we had
criteria that required
confirmation of the diagnosis and the
level of degree of cirrhosis that a
patient had at the time we had some
other questions that we asked around it
before we would cover the treatment and
over the years as the price has come
down and the treatment is highly
effective there we have lowered the
barriers so now for uh individual newly
diagnosed with Hepatitis C we no longer
require prior authorization if it's
their first course of treatment
if they need a second course of
treatment then we would
um then we have a prior authorization
are the I'm sorry I'm monopolizing this
conversation for which I apologize uh
I'll speak to that in a few minutes
while I'm monopolizing
um are there other diagnoses
that come across your desk where the
treatment is less effective
but still approvable
or the cost is extraordinary but given
certain circumstances we might have
proven anyway
that's loaded question I'm sorry yes
there there are so
um
you know there are uh well there was a
newer treatment for Alzheimer's that was
in the news quite a bit that
um
the clinical trials didn't show the drug
to be as effective as they had hoped it
would be
um and so we do have prior authorization
requirements around that we have not or
my department has not received any
requests for prior authorization for
that treatment at this time and I
understand that the manufacturer is no
longer
um
uh I think they've backed off on
promoting that drug because it didn't
have a very high Effectiveness rating
thank you thank you so are there other
questions
for Ms Clifford
representative Woods oh thank you um
thanks for taking my question uh in your
prior authorization process do you still
uh use the outsort you mentioned some of
the effectiveness of this is referred to
outs and is outsourced with
pre-authorizations is that also the case
so the effectiveness of the treatment
doesn't factor into our prior
authorization if a drug
if the manufacturer of a drug
participates with the federal drug
rebate program we can put some clinical
guidelines around it but those clinical
guidelines don't really
um we don't have one that looks at
effectiveness of the drug we really are
focused on whether or not they have the
disease that the drug is indicated for
and
um
other if there's other specifics that
you know
well if it comes to like a biomarker if
they need a certain Gene for that drug
to have the potential to work you know
then that would be something we would
look at because if they don't have the
gene that's necessary the drug is not
going to work and therefore they
wouldn't meet the criteria to receive
that coverage
getting back to the prior authorization
which is a significant significant
sticking point in the medical community
both Statewide and nationally
um again my question is do you Outsource
pre-authorizations uh for any of these
you know medications
so it
if you're asking about who actually
reviews the prior auth for the Medicaid
fee for service population which is
primarily what I'm responsible for we we
have Magellan RX management as our
Pharmacy benefit manager the initial
review is done by them but we don't
allow Magellan to issue any denials if
they if they feel that a member doesn't
meet the criteria then it's sent to my
team myself and there's another
pharmacist that works for me at Medicaid
and we review and if we agree with the
decision the denial is issued by us not
by the um not by the vendor
so
if I understand it correctly with a
pre-authorization uh it goes through
pbms
to see if it's in their
Pharmacy formulary
and research criteria
if it doesn't then it comes back in
in-house in the in-house
is then makes the decision that's
correct for the FIFA service population
what about the other non for the
Medicaid Managed Care organizations they
do their own review we we do review and
approve their prior authorization
criteria
but the individual decisions uh whether
or not it's covered is up to each MCL
and the members do have an appeal
process and beyond that appeal process
there's
um a state fair hearing that they can go
to and at that point
um it's reviewed by
um
by the state
okay thank you I
um I understand that this review process
is pretty much like examining snowflakes
each each case is is pretty unique in
terms of of uh what the disease
condition is and and whether or not to
what extent the individual may have an
effective result
nevertheless I'm curious if there's an
opportunity here
um to do an external Benchmark on
occasion to take a look at what other
states are doing in this area and and if
there is an opportunity are we taking
advantage of it
we do often
um
I'm part of a list serve for with the
Medicaid Pharmacy directors from the
other states and we often have
discussions about how other states are
covering it and take that into
consideration and a lot of times we
share our criteria from state to state
thank you
so there is not
a uniform Federal standard
and the availability
of a diagnostic procedure or an
intervention under Medicaid
could vary depending on where you live
is that correct well the requirement to
cover a drug under under the Medicaid
Program is is the same the criteria from
state to K State can be slightly
different but we
oftentimes have very similar criteria
and we we share criteria with each other
I'm sorry I'm
it's an editorial comment a Medicaid
patient having to navigate
these kinds of procedures
to procure a treatment for a serious
disease I'm just
yeah wow
further questions
a follow-up sir okay so this is uh an
editorial comment to your editorial
comment uh my my understanding would be
that it isn't the patient necessarily
that's doing the navigation of of this
procedure but it's care providers who
believe that this would be a good
treatment plan and then go through the
process to ensure that they can
prescribe it to their patient is is it
more provider driven going through your
process or more patient driven you yes
you're correct it's more provider driven
so it's it's up to the treating provider
to request the authorization if a prior
authorization is necessary
and provide the supporting documentation
to show that the member meets the
if I might that's the nature of medical
practice right now part of the paperwork
and it's where the pickle comes in
that some of the pre-authors and
pre-authorization not just in this
instance but across the board for a wide
variety of you know medications
procedures and Etc it creates a
significant paperwork Trail and onus
within the um any an individual office
and and has been shown I don't know the
frequency but pre-authorization is a
used as a mechanism to constrain Medical
Care
representative could you repeat that
last sentence please
the the
pre-authorization process has been shown
on occasion
to be used by some entities which will
remain unnamed to constrain health care
payment
and coverage
I I just need to hold that thought
in my mind thank you
so further now it's gonna clarify but
okay you are saying that
pre-authorization
has periodically or or or or
sporadically been used to restrain
access to care and the costs but that
we're not
saying that there's a systemic abuse of
pre-authorizations no not at all I I
said I tried to clarify that that on
occasion right right I just wanted to
get our notes right yeah correct no
you're absolutely correct this has been
just like some doctors have been shown
to
apply for uh Medicare Medicaid debt
coverage uh uh falsely
um I mean it just it's one of the
difficulties that we face and uh when
the
pre-authorization process uh it gets
trickled down uh to being outsourced and
then someone in Kansas uh who's maybe a
pediatrician may be making a
determination for our company because
they're on a panel that reviews for that
company and they may be a pediatrician
in Kansas
making a determination on a surgical
patient in New Hampshire
that's a true Case by the way
so so I'm I'm sympathetic to your
observation I used to handle billing for
positron emission tomography back in the
good old days when I was still
clinically experimental and so each of
these was navigating an individual payer
and and I I understand what you're
saying
representative Kim
thank you Mr chair
um
Has are has have we seen a number of
cases and if so do you know how many
here in New Hampshire may have been
brought forward to Medicaid for
consideration for payment
um I don't have any numbers with me but
we could look at that and get back to
you we do have
um
if you're familiar with the Department's
uh quality website there are I believe
there's a report on there that shows the
number of Prior authorizations and the
approval and denial rates for those
oh
follow-up
now I'm well I'm hoping that'll be just
be able to understand the scope as we
look at this issue is are we on the
early edge of things or is this
something that we're going to have to
take a look at in the future so for the
Precision medicine I don't know um that
we have anything that separates out
those numbers I think in general we look
at all prior authorizations the number
of requests and approvals and denials of
those requests and
um one thing to to bear in mind when you
do look at the number of or percentage
of denials the the treatment may have
been denied for that particular drug but
it doesn't mean that they didn't get
another treatment so sometimes what
happens with high cost drugs is that
there's what's called Step through
therapy so before you get to the higher
cost drug you have to try this less
expensive treatment first so the high
cost drug might have been denied but a
lower cost alternative may have been
provided in its place
follow up representative Edwards thank
you I want to go back to the external
benchmarking and the listserv process
um okay so in my my experience when you
do external benchmarking you can find
that your organization is kind of in the
mainstream where you can find that that
your organization is more aggressive or
less aggressive and and therefore
there's some correction process that
typically happens and the norming of the
standards
intuitively where do you think New
Hampshire is when we do external
benchmarking are we pretty much in The
Sweet Spot or are we you know lagging
are we leading what just what's your
sense uh that's something I'd have to
ask someone from the quality unit
um because they they are the ones that
look at all those performance measures
and and know where we sit
along with other states so that's
something we could get back to you on
foreign
without meaning to add measurably to the
burdens of your daily work
um would it be possible to get some of
these data uh just send them to me via
email that I can distribute to the
committee yes
um I can I can access the reports that
I'm talking about that are on the
website and send you the link or I can
just download a copy and send them to
you whichever you prefer the link would
be adequate thank you for that or copies
would be
gratefully received and we can get them
forwarded and or photocopied for the
committee okay
further questions from Miss Clifford
Ms Clifford I must say for somebody who
had to be coached in to testify
you have contributed significantly to
our deliberations and I'm personally
grateful to you thank you all right
representative Woods
excuse me if I can offer a comment on on
benchmarking I don't mean this is
any kind of derogatory comment about
your what you're saying the difficulty
is with Precision medicine and we're
getting us back to the technical aspects
is that that there are a wide variety of
parameters that come into play both uh
within the FDA the CDC and so forth in
recommending orphan drugs
um or other procedures
and that is on like we did with coveted
vaccines it was
um okay on an emergency basis because it
didn't meet the full criteria of the
significant database
um so I I think as we go forward and we
look at the criteria used uh are they
using the English system uh in the
National Health Care system if they
still lose I think they do
um when they're um uh offering
um their um
okay on a drug they have two two
criteria one is safety which allows it
to be released if it's perfectly safe
but they don't have the numbers for
efficacy
uh they allow it to be released for
General use
in the U.S one of the reasons that it
takes so long to get something because
you have to show safety and efficacy
as a consequence there's a significant
delay
oftentimes getting it into the General
Public
with orphan drugs the FDA has the
premature of offering the previous I.E
the English system of saying it's safe
and will release it under these under
the guise of this with certain criteria
and they become and those criteria then
become individualized
um
so as we go forward uh looking at the
criteria which is they say they you know
follow the CDC or FDA and all the other
criteria it may vary depending upon what
it is that they're dealing with I don't
mean to add complexity to this but it is
complex
um and um I just wanted to offer and I
just uh
cautionary comment
s
right information so information is
neutral it's just information
uh I just didn't want to step on anybody
until I said I want to make a comment
about benchmarking I just I I wasn't
trying to correct you or anything at all
if I just wanted to add
to what you said uh I I want to shift
gears here I believe we have no further
testimony
and therefore I'd like to move in the
direction of discussion this is because
we do not have a quorum this is not an
executive session
it is a working discussion
um for which we will take General notes
but we will take no action in terms of a
vote
the Prelude to the discussion however
comes with a review of our minutes
uh which depicts uh representative Woods
comments of our last meeting followed by
representative Merchants comments in
that meeting which
this is a member of our committee who is
Senator we are currently in session I'm
afraid I can't talk right now but I must
warn you you are on speakerphone and my
microphone is open be careful what you
say
drop it down told me now for two weeks
oh dear Sandra I hope you get better and
I will communicate with you when this
meeting is over
bye
um
we're
we
in case nobody's noticed it
we have a surge of a new variant of
covet it's going on around us
uh we really haven't done a very good
job of identifying it and we really
don't know how effective vaccination is
in preventing it
however I am seeing individuals such as
Senator Guida who you just heard from
um who are in their second round
of acute covid and it appears to be a
pretty serious round of covet uh just
they'll notice now let me go back to my
comments so uh representative woods and
representative Merchant did a wonderful
job at our last meeting of refocusing
the discussion
and they pointed out that
if we abide by the criteria of proven
effectiveness
the specific topic before us of
precision medicine has not been subject
to the kind of clinical trials
um not simply
the double-blind studies but not even
the case control studies or the cohort
studies that would lead us to confidence
that this intervention though very
costly
significantly reduces the burden of
disease
in following their testimony
um I conferred extensively with uh the
chairman of Finance 3 who is sitting
here with US Representative Edwards with
the chairman of the oversight committee
representative Pearson I spoke to uh
uh uh people on the house Judiciary
Committee to see what our options were
in terms of of legal obligations I've
had conversation with councilor Williams
and
um have uh these consensus emerging
that what our task is is not necessarily
to Simply review Precision medicine
but to create a task force of the
oversight committee a standing task
force
to review emerging medical Technologies
and
to assess these Technologies uh on a
continuing basis at the call of the
chair of the task force so I drafted a
very simple uh suggested recommended uh
action for the oversight committee which
if this
subcommittee approved and we don't have
enough a quorum to approve it but I'd
like to discuss it which we could bring
you had together which we could bring to
oversight
um as our final recommendation I'm going
Mr chair just so you know I'm I'm really
comfortable with us talking about a
draft
oh yeah I think we're as we're well
within our guidelines to talk about a
draft and and and if we're making
suggestions that may
if if we're making suggestions that may
cause us to redraft a draft I I don't
but
when you're ready I have some comments
on the draft
pursue it to this discussion
we will redraft
and presented at our next meeting for uh
consideration assuming we have a quorum
please uh representative Edwards give us
your recommendations okay I I think if
if we're going to end up with an LSR and
a bill that it it may be very useful to
have a purpose and intense section added
so that people understand what we're
doing why we're doing it you know as
people who aren't in the Committees
won't have a clue so that that's one
suggestion uh then another for just
clarification
um
it reads now it is recommended that the
oversight committee submit to the House
and Senate companion bills which
establish a standing task force on
medical Technologies and for clarity I I
think you're saying that that task force
should be within HHS oversight or are
you wanting it to be independent of HHS
or HHS oversight where where do you see
I I think uh it it should be under
um
I think I'm going to let Mr Williams
correct me but I think it should be a
task force under HHS not HHS oversight
uh oversight I think is is is built more
around the notion of staying current
with what's happening and and and and
being basically the the guardian for the
public to make sure everything's going
well I think HHS is a policy committee
and as a policy committee uh this task
force would tend to come up with
long-term policy implications so so I
see it as fitting more comfortably as a
task force under HHS and not HHS
oversight
and
would that include members of the Senate
as well as the house
I I think you can do joint
um and I don't know how you would
organize it then at that point that that
does complicate it
um
the HHS oversight's already a joint
Senate house thing right so so I don't
know if it's
um easier to do it under oversight
because we're already aligned to the
Senate as well but it's it's a longer
term policy issue
chair
um representative Edwards is absolutely
correct in many capacities in his
recommendations to the committee
currently the committee already has at
least one existing other committee that
falls under it as a permanent committee
but it's separate distinct as he points
out uh from The Joint legislative
committee itself the example that is
cited uh was enacted back around 2015
and it relates to a permanent committee
under the HHS oversight committee for
dementia and Related Disorders and so
there is an example for you to follow
out there and it's actually codified
under RSA 126a colon 15 a lowercase a
and if you create a new entity which is
what I believe representative Edwards
was quite correctly pointing out for an
approach it would be it would fall under
the umbrella of the larger parent
committee however it is separate and
distinct from that committee and would
have a reporting obligation back to the
larger committee on its signings and
recommendations so you do have a
template out there that's already in
existence and as you may recall the
underlying bill that was the predicate
for this uh this task force subcommittee
being created I believe it was HP 1280
you may want to double check on that
number but that bill actually
contemplated exactly what you were
recommending representative Edwards for
the creation of a permanent subcommittee
under our permanent subcommittee under
the HHS oversight and it gives you a lot
of your language what it may also
contain as well is the purpose and
intent language I believe that was
included in there as well however given
the work that's been done by this
committee you may want to have your own
touch and to add your facts and findings
as well for the general report as to the
need for creation of the sub committee
under a permanent subcommittee under HHS
oversight so I hope that's helpful
I it it's very helpful
um the uh and I believe that the issues
of
purpose and intent
and the creation of a
um
standing subcommittee are fine
I'm always interested in the
implementation in that one would have to
recruit members of such a task force
uh this is of course always the purview
of the chair
um
and it has been difficult certainly in
this session
to recruit
uh members of subcommittees so that we
can get the work done please note there
are four members of the House present at
this meeting here today are senatorial
members are not represented here today
for a variety of reasons and we have
members of the house that are absent
it's very difficult to pull this off and
the only question in my mind
representative is
um
whether we will be able to recruit to
implement
I just
worry about that
okay just
so the recruitment issue is there
regardless of where we set this thing up
right so so that problem is just a
challenge
um
right now I'm just trying to focus on on
where to place it I think Mr Williams uh
is uh suggesting very diplomatically
that maybe HHS oversight is the right
way to set this up
as an aside it's a little disturbing to
find out that there is already one of
these for dementia and Alzheimer's that
I'm just unaware of and I'm I'm the vice
chair of oversight I didn't know that so
so so what that makes me wonder is you
know how did I get to be so ignorant or
alternatively has that uh committee that
task force become Obsolete and just quit
showing up for business and and if it
did then then what would we need to do
differently to not also build an auto
dying task force
if I can build on your comments which I
think are quite germane
we have Within
I don't know whether it's in within the
house or within the committee on Health
Human Services and elderly Affairs or
oversight
um
task forces on specific issues that
simply have not met
so even here
um
I use the language
I believe uh meet at the call of the
chair
and we have
a task words I don't care to mention it
because people will know who the chair
is
um and the chair has simply not called
meetings of that task force and we would
run the risk
of having a task force on the books
uh in the chair not calling meetings and
therefore the work not getting done the
other possibility that we need to think
when we talk about implementation is
when we identify the general category of
emerging medical Technologies it is also
possible that a task force could be
quite overwhelmed
with the number of emerging medical
technologies that require review
that were pertinent to the operation of
Medicaid
uh that might represent significant
costs to the state
and the task force would have to review
any number of these and that's that's a
lot of work
so I'm concerned about the issue of
implementation how are you going to do
it make it work right and maybe that's
not for us to decide maybe that's for
the chairman of oversight to decide well
we're still making a recommendation
yeah
oh please representative Woods if I if I
might uh thank you
um I I think we're trying to send to me
uh we're trying to send a message that
this this area
medical Technologies in general needs to
be addressed in some way
okay that's a very vague statement but I
think you're absolutely correct that
there will be conceivably an absolutely
overwhelming I mean overwhelming demand
for its those services
um
I worked with a group that was trying to
look at a breast cancer evaluation yeah
and the issue of fast MRIS
um versus you know tomography and
regular MRIs fasting or is a technology
that's relatively new
and that they said well gee we want the
the uh a blessing of this committee
and then who who uh who who uh initiates
that and there's a multitude of niche
kinds of things that would come to the
fore
um and how that gets put through some
kind of sieve uh it would be is going to
be interesting because the potential is
is just
um I mean it's I mean this is from AI to
nanoparticles uh to crispr uh I mean is
I mean it is it is unbelievably Broad
and I think there is a risk that it
could be overwhelmed and the mechanism
there has to be some kind of mechanism
to have it be focused and whether it's
the chair of the oversight committee or
someone in HHS
I'm not sure and just it's just a
comment
foreign
calling up the collective wisdom in this
room
that would include our uh test uh our
testifiers
all of them
is this a repeat
of a process that goes on at the federal
level at FDA at perhaps CDC
at uh
uh CMS is it are we
doing what they are already doing
or are we making decisions de novo you
know new decisions that apply only
within our state
so
uh
if Miss Clifford
bound or oriented by CMS for example
um is it necessary for us to do that
work over again
or do we simply say well it's already
getting done we don't have to do it
uh my tank here is the role that
committee would be to evaluate exactly
how they reached that decision
um there are the U.S task force
um which we're all familiar with uh uh
and is is sometimes quoted rather
extensively is as a you know really a
gold standard
but in the medical community it is not
the gold standard and I can cite several
examples where they went awry
um and um I won't get into detail but I
think the same
cautious approach would have to be taken
and not just blanketly adopt well the
CDC said okay the FDA said okay or the
STP are forgotten The Liberation U.S
task force uh said okay and adopt it
um my sense is would be to take a firmer
look
to see how they arrived at that
looking at the decisions made by the FDA
in the past two and a half years
representative
and looking at decisions that I know
have come out of CDC
uh having been in contact with Rochelle
wolinski
um who I know from a different venue
entirely about what she found when she
took over the CDC
the decisions that we get at the federal
level uh representative Edward she will
be surprised to hear this
those decisions are often as much
um
often economic and financial rather than
scientific
and
um
as a small state I don't know that we
have the resources
to review their reasoning in detail but
I must say that I have
not uncommonly found their reasoning
suspect
yeah
I would offer an example of the 5G
commission that looked at the radiation
and the role of the scfcc
in establishing medical criteria and
that was found to be deficient and
actually they're in the process of being
sued because they uh
performed uh of course a policy
determination without actually
performing the work
and it's that kind of
review
the commission did look at and was able
to say that a further comments are
needed in this area and I think this the
committee we're referring to would would
hopefully be able to find that same
same source and of in of information
having several experts here
I would have to ask whether a an
emerging medical Technologies task force
here in New Hampshire might likewise be
absolutely
and hopefully
the people on that would have sufficient
standing and sufficient fortitude to be
able to go to sometimes even the
original sources and I I I refer to that
again back to the 5G commission or on
that commission we looked at some of the
scientific detail and were able to
contact people who actually did the work
and found that they were being misquoted
in some instances and I would think that
the commission would do would do the do
the same
foreign
go ahead
okay so I I think in general in the last
couple decades we've been seeing the
erosion of rigor in a lot of the
scientific communities and the increased
politicization of of that's replacing it
and so anything we do is subject to the
same sort of environmental threat but
but that doesn't mean we shouldn't do
something and so so so I would like to
maybe come at this for a moment just to
explore an alternative path
um I know under DHHS
we have contracts with UNH to where they
loan us professors for specific things
and I'm not saying professors are immune
from politics by any means uh professor
saloy
but I just wonder if uh if we're we're
trying to craft essentially an academic
task to take a look at emerging Trends
and and Technologies and to be an early
identifier of significance that that
that if there that sounds like an
academic Pursuit more than the
legislative Pursuit and so I'm wondering
if this is something that we should
consider as a potential add-on or tweak
of a DHHS mission
and I'm not recommending it I'm just
saying is that a viable alternative what
are the advantages and disadvantages how
does it stack against the other
alternatives
I don't have any real strong preference
I think regardless of how it's uh uh
ultimately situated it's going to depend
on the individuals within whatever
committee that is to be able to to
really
hold forth uh academically I mean
academic in the non-political sense for
them to hold forth and any committee
regards of where it's situated could in
fact uh fall awry
uh and I think it would depend on the
people picked and and their individual
fortitude and their Collective fortitude
uh again regardless of their where
they're situated it's going to require
that and this is that kind of effort
that's going to require uh really uh um
a strong individual and a strong
Collective effort
s
so I just wonder if if we're talking
about a legislative committee are we
asking a fish to fly in other words you
know we are inherently a political body
and we're asking for somebody to be
devoid of politics and be a an honest
broker of an Arbiter of of Truth and
visions and I just wonder if
maybe the initial premise is flawed of
I would completely agree if it's just
a legislative body
um my surmise and and in the graph that
we see here it doesn't identify that
this is a legislative
subcommittee it just says that the chair
shall identify who that constitutes that
subcommittee uh and that gives a
tremendous amount of attitude I would
certainly think there would be a you
know some legislative to give some
guidance when could we want to translate
this into policy at some point
but my essentially the way this is
drafted is would be that the chair uh
and again whether in the final form
there would be some direction that the
chair must have this
kind of constituency but my sense would
be that the intent a paragraph that
you've identified would be that this is
indeed a a scientific review and
requires the
expertise to accomplish that and clearly
the vast majority and I don't mean to be
exclusive of anyone but the vast
majority of legislators don't
have a a a a scientific founding to
allow them to sit on such a committee
and therefore I think the predominance
of individuals populating that committee
would in fact be none legislators and uh
but again it depends on the individuals
but again I would allow the uh an
initial paragraph to identify the intent
of what this is for uh and make it clear
what we want to accomplish and the fact
that it does require a lot of scientific
input
um I one of the things I in trying to
investigate to learn more about
Precision medicine medicine especially
being a carpenter and a truck driver and
stuff that
um I did notice online that there are
numerous
organizations that are holding
conferences entire conferences to
understand more about
Precision medicine from many different
perspectives and uh and and so I I think
that having an ongoing task force sort
of monitor some of those discussions and
some of the outcomes is probably one of
the best things that we can do at this
time because there don't seem to be any
concrete
uh
Health and Human Services and elderly
affairs
overall and oversight is that we wind up
using the 30 000 foot perspective
uh to get an idea of where we are where
we're going I think we're doing that
here today and that's extremely useful
and we have substantial consensus here
that we are a community in the
legislature Senate and House of Citizen
legislators okay
who do not necessarily have specific
expertise in any area
but what we have is the opportunity to
appoint members of task forces as
Citizens and and to solicit expert
testimony
to educate legislators and to help in
the formulation of policy so I think if
we redraft this
expert experts who are citizen members
of a task force not necessarily a
majority but a few and to insist on
solicited testimony
from people in the professional
communities I think if we redraft it
that way we can use those two tools
appointments to the to the committee of
the task force and solicited testimony
to create a fund of knowledge that would
be useful
just a reminder that we discussed
earlier the likely possibility that this
task force could well be overwhelmed
with the need to review a number of
Technologies
for which
there really isn't a lot of data
and I think that's that's going to
happen
okay
um further comments I got another story
so I'm still learning about the um
prescription drug affordability board
and as uh
representative Woods pointed out the
opportunities are extremely diverse on
what's what areas of science and
technology that this could overlap with
or intersect with and and so I'm just
curious does do we think that the um the
the prescription drug affordability
board already has a charter or could
have a charter amended so that they
looked at an emerging biomarker issues I
mean that's that's one of the big parts
of this
and and it's just an open question I
have no opinion
Mr chair
oh please um I would view the committee
or some community that we're discussing
would not be involved at the same level
that that board uh the affordability
board
my sense would be this would be looking
at doesn't have does any particular item
have scientific Merit
once that has been yay or nayed then the
affordability becomes another issue you
know are there Grant programs for
supporting it do pbms have too high a
level of criteria
that these are the kinds of things once
it's been
clarified that it does meet scientific
scientific criteria now I I I would view
these as really separate once the
scientific aspect has been determined
then the business aspect of it would
come into play that's where I view the
affordability board
that was an interesting suggestion
and until representative wood spoke I
thought wow you know we could merge the
drug affordability uh for into this but
I think he's correct I think yes could
we get Mr Williams a comment on the
other idea that maybe the DHHS
commission like between then but since
we have these academic relationships
anyways whether there's a potential
so when when you say
that representative Williams you're
going to be on the hot seat in just a
second
whether so would you put this within
DHHS
within the committee on Health and Human
Services elderly Affairs are within the
task force are you suggesting that It Go
within DHHS okay so so this is an
exploration of brainstorming effort at
alternative ways of getting to the
objective an alternative way to get to
the objective may be uh to task DHHS
with uh providing us with the brush
breaking that's necessary to to scan the
environment of emerging Science and
Technology to help identify those areas
that should be of long-term interest to
the uh the legislature and and I don't
view that as being substantially
different than some of the things we ask
DHHS to do on our behalf anyways when
they start to see Trends in federal
legislation or or in other areas they
they initiate a relationship with
somebody in the legislature a powerful
Senator uh you know a compliant
representative but they they could they
reach out and say hey here's this is
coming on can can we talk about it there
may be a legislative approach or the
that's necessary here and so so I'm just
wondering if we should just formalize
maybe a DHHS responsibility rather than
worrying about creating a whole task
force
can if I can piggyback an inquiry onto
yours and address it to
councilor Williams yes sir um
do you have within DHHS a silo if you
will a department and office that would
be responsible for the assessment of
medical Technologies Effectiveness and
or cost
who would you ask to do that
and represents always chair I just
wanted to before uh responding to the
questions posed by representative
Edwards and yourself uh that the
underlying bill that was the um basis
for this committee being created to
starting things off was actually house
built 1290 9-0 so I missed it by one
digit or ten digits based upon how you
view that
um so
um a benefit I think to this group and I
think continuity of membership attending
is always important because I I was
thinking to myself sitting in the
gallery I wish that represent Merchant
was part of this conversation because he
was here last week and he would see how
the evolving conversations are happening
how best to identify and address it I
think there have been very thoughtful
additions to the discussions uh as we're
looking at your your proposal I do think
that representative Edwards when he
identified that this is an academic
Pursuit when you're answering at least
one of the threshold questions which is
uh and then getting to rep some woods
from the last meeting where he talked
about the Journey of I believe your was
his great grandfather who rode horseback
in Texas prior to the date uh date it
could have been a great rate but I'm
pretty sure a great grandfather
um great great
um and so um how the world of medicine
has evolved since the days of riding uh
the ranges
um to creation of hospitals and up to
now Precision medicine one of the
questions that was asked at the last
meeting was whether and a particular
measure of precision medicine was
effective or not was a threshold
question and that was flushed out a bit
in the in the conversations that you had
at the last meeting with that said that
gets to the practice of medicine which
gets exactly to what representative
Edwards was mentioning about this being
an academic Pursuit or perhaps one for
the world of medicine or the field of
medicine to assist in identifying as
these are are being you know evolving in
the process I do think that
representative Cannon also identified
that there's these groups that are out
there that are looking at this issue
very meaningfully in trying to getting
the answers to these questions so that
you don't have to exhaust resources on
your own to try to determine what others
are already well ahead of us in the
conversation for determining what works
and doesn't work as it relates to the
department I one of the things that we
wanted to make very clear that we are
definitely here we're definitely present
we want to participate in the process
but the world of Medicaid just as it is
with the world of affordable
Pharmaceuticals drugs that we're a small
part a very important part but a small
part of a larger Mosaic that deals with
also private ARS commercial insurance as
well as Medicare and so the pursuit
that's being asked to the department
specifically here I'd have to address
that we do not have in-house expertise
and I'll repeat that we do not have the
in-house expertise to address the
threshold question about what types of
Precision Precision medicines work and
which ones do not that would have to be
an engagement of the experts in the
field whether you do it as represent
Canon was suggesting through looking out
those entities out there that are
currently working at this at a national
level and or looking at it from how
representative Edwards is suggesting
because there are some practical models
with the resources provided however for
the Department to engage in new areas
that we haven't done before but we would
have to have the leveraging of either
financial resources and or the ability
to contract with the resources through
the academic world UNH and whatnot to
try to do that so I think that's a
question for you as a group to identify
where do you see this going in terms of
addressing that initial threshold
question what Precision medicine
actually has value which works and which
ones do not work and whether you want to
review a little more deeply what it
would look like at a state level for the
Department to be given resources to
contract with Academia to start looking
at this issue or do you want to look at
what represent Cannon was saying looking
at a national level is the resources out
there ncsl for example would be a good
resource to have those conversations
with or maybe you're looking at a blend
of both of those Pursuits being being
done but I understood also that in
addition to that threshold question
about which Precision medicines work are
do not work the other component here
that is very helpful and does have a
political lens to it which is they pay
our perspective because the fact that
something works the question then
becomes from an economic standpoint is
there a value to that and there's great
conversations at your last meeting
relative to balancing out the the worth
of what we we do and I'll just refer to
your draft minutes which you can take
action on at your next meeting uh to get
into some of those areas but I think
that's a real critical part and one of
the reasons it was mentioned by reps and
Merchant I believe
to having this is a permanent
subcommittee under HHS oversight in
other words not directly the
responsibility of the parent committee
but having its own entity out there was
because you're not going to address all
these issues within the course of a
biennium as you know HHS oversight has
the authority creating subcommittees
task force whatever you'd like to do
including at least a legislative member
as your chair but you can have other
members of the public also serving on
those as well the downside to it is just
like the HHS parent committee every
biennium they Sunset and has to be
reconstituted every next biennium so
knowing that the issues over what
medicines work or don't work from
Precision medicine is a longitudinal a
long conversation much longer than
you're going to have in a biennium
and then the other real significant
issue which we'll need the assistance of
the legislature and making findings or
recommendations is how do you pay for
these and and what are the ones that are
are should be paid for and I think you
it ties back into the medical advocacy
of your foundational questions but until
you uh you address both those issues
meaningfully you you won't even get to
the point of access to the public
meaningfully around it now are there
efforts being made you heard from rather
from our Medicaid pharmacist uh Peg
Clifford uh that we certainly already
through Medicaid provide certain
services around Precision medicine and
uh through our agency but the goal here
I understood was to build on represent
Rogers or Roger's vision of a more
robust use of precision medicine within
our state so I know there's a lot that I
put out there and I hope that in some
ways it didn't cause more confusion
because I think that the conversations
are very thoughtful in terms of
identifying which functions should fall
under one area in which function should
follow under another whether it's
Academia or a committee that's launched
leveraging the resources for those
academics to report back information but
ultimately there will have to be some
type of legislative findings and
recommendations as to access and how to
pay for these
um so I will stop that was a lot and
there's some oxygen still left in groups
well it's a trigger question
two questions
uh okay are we aware of any state in our
region that's already done something
similar or is moving towards doing
something similar
in terms of monitoring the future
and it could be no that we just don't
know what the other states are doing I
represent you I don't have that
information so I don't know what other
states have been doing okay so a
straight thought on that is you know if
there's another state in our region and
maybe we just do a collaboration
and then another one and maybe this is
more for for for you Professor salloway
um if we were to if we were to take a
walk through the halls of Academia
Dartmouth and UNH would we find
um an academic who this is already an
area of interest for him or her and and
what we're really just trying to do is
to find that person who's already making
thank you representative
um if you'll permit me a moment of
discussion
um a very long time ago
when I was young and I am very old at
this point excuse me
[Laughter]
I hit two areas of expertise in my
research
one of them was Alzheimer's
and the other was organ donation and
transplantation
and that included by the way because in
1965 when I was beginning this sort of
thing we passed the end-stage renal
disease Act
which basically said the federal
government will pay for dialysis as well
when we began taking a look at organ
donation and transplantation and
dialysis
we had a limited number of dialysis
couches
at Major Medical Centers and we could
not service the entire population of
people with end-stage renal disease
we had a very limited supply of donor
kidneys we still have a very limited
supply of donor kidneys
so the question became
how do we allocate
dialysis Services how do we allocate
transplant good precious organs for
transplantation
and to make those decisions this will
become relevant in just a second
to make those determinations medical
centers that we're doing uh dialysis and
Transplant constituted review committees
to assess each individual case
those committees typically included a
surgeon because they were going to do
the cutting
in the case of dialysis and nephrologist
and a Internal Medicine physician social
workers
who would assess the quality of life of
the individual patients and clergy
because these were ethical
considerations
a service on those committees by the
people who were appointed
was emotionally exhausting
because they were making life and death
decisions for individuals they were
making decisions that affected not just
patients but families in some cases
communities
um what we're talking about constituting
is a similar Commission on a much larger
scale
that will assess
is a technology and I've shifted from
Precision medicine to Medical Technology
urging medical technology
is a technology effective and effective
for whom and what are the criteria by
which we shall decide for whom we will
fund a technology for whom we will not
this is going to be difficult and
exhausting work
and while I think that we have done a
wonderful job of sorting this out and
I'm grateful for the suggestions of
including experts from the University of
New Hampshire from Dartmouth Medical
School practitioners in the community
I'm you know very grateful for that and
we'll craft it into a draft uh
resolution for next time
I don't know how you're going to
convince those people
to do this emotionally exhausting work
and it's going to be a lot of work uh
please representative Woods
um I hear about perhaps a slightly
different view which may solve part of
your problem
I view the task force that were looked
to address is only looking at and to use
your example of kidney transplants
that task force that we're talking about
would only be asked to address is it
scientifically correct to do a kidney
transplant is it at that level that we
can and the answer would be yes it would
not answer the question how are you
going to fund it how and whom you would
make selection for that procedure or the
all the other dimensions that you
described and therefore would not have
to address that in in the larger sense
but only provide the basis
for the decision that in fact there is
sufficient scientific evidence to move
forward and so I I view it my personal
view it's a slightly different much more
constrained
representative I'm going to enjoy
hoisting you on your own petard
so let us say Sir that you are seated on
such a task force and that is not an
unlikely probability
and let us say that you have a gallery
filled with people who have a person
um
within their family that has breast
cancer
and they are crying for uh stem cell
transplant to treat it or
um they have a patient with another form
of cancer they believe leotro will work
it's going to get better in just a
second okay or they are terrified of
covet and would like to have a
prescription for Ivermectin
and
it is now your responsibility
to make the decision on your committee
to vote Yes we should allow this no we
should not allow it
that's the situation that this task
force is going to end up in
nope
that's correct but it is it's not the
secondary decisions that I was I want
you to said yes that procedure can go
forward okay
um and the audience then would have that
information then next comes the question
of funding and and selection which that
can be in my understanding or my
perception it would not be involved
it then goes directly to representative
so I I need to like step back and say
I'm confused about the scope of what
this task force is intended to do I I
mean I'm I'm gonna
in 1984 I actually took a class in
research and development so I'm going to
try to remember that there used to be
this this phasing of research and
development
category one two three four and the
bigger the number The Closer Closer you
got to commercial development of
something but the the the research that
was done in one was was thought to be
basic research uh not applied in any way
so so so what I've imagined this task
force to be doing is to be sort of
standing guard looking at what kinds of
issues are coming into uh the the first
phase of research
and maybe seems viable for the second
phase
and not still hanging on when it's
hitting phase four with commercial
applications and so so as you were
giving a hypothetical about this
committee engaging a particular patient
scenario I I think this task force would
be long long out of the discussion by
the time it got to an actual patient
seeking actual care I I see this as sort
of like in the military you have an
intelligence Community who sits and
tries to identify what the what the what
the threat may be and then prioritize
the threat in this case we'd be doing
the same thing but we'd be doing it for
opportunities what are the opportunities
what are the potential of the
opportunities so so we would have an
intelligence group that would be looking
at these potential opportunities and
then alert hurting the legislature that
something's coming down the pike for
which there may be a policy implication
I I don't see this committee that we've
been theoretically talking about or
talking about theoretically
as as being Hands-On once
the technology is mature enough and
sufficiently digested by the system to
be relevant to any human
no you and I okay
because I do do you see the distinction
I'm trying to make and what you yeah
okay yep so you're asking for a scope
your term yeah
which is General
is
um alerts
the oversight committee to issues that
will arise yeah that suggests that the
that will make recommendations to
oversight
for the specifics but does not itself
draw up the specifics it says this is an
area in which you you'd better be
looking and you'd better think somebody
may want to be drafting an LSR on this
particular issue much more that than
what I thought I heard in terms of
application of of who should get what
yeah if I misspoke I I'm very much in
the track of making the scientific
decision and the applications then
follow and the example I always give is
bardeen uh got uh fourteen thousand
dollar Grant to look at uh doping in
Silicon
Adobe is where you put yeah abnormal
atoms within silicon germanium
specifically and I played with and I
said why are you giving 14 000 in the
solid state physicist to play games with
silicon and running
um
um germanium atoms around in it uh well
out of that came
all of computers
that's the PN Junction or the positive
negative Junction uh that became the
transistor and the transistors gave
their computer so out of fourteen
thousand dollars we have
all of our computer industry
all of it
so that's why uh he didn't do any of
that work he just did the Fourteen
thousand dollar Grant found out you
could control the germanium and silicon
and the rest is history and I view this
committee the same as we're looking at
not germanium and silicon but we're
looking at this technology applied to a
human being
do they mesh and if we say no
if we say yes
further discussion at this point I just
remember the term I was searching for
the level one was just called basic
research yep and not not did not the
commercial research that's done in phase
four
uh
in the previous life
you went from
theoretical determinations to Cellular
studies to uh
threat models
I'm sorry to say this to dogs and then
you know eventually sorry
um
a footnote a personal note not to be
recorded I once walked into the dog lab
I never walked in again
uh and then you know to
the first human trials and then
ultimately to uh the
um
clinical trials you know that okay so I
need some garden furniture I I don't
think I could possibly cover this entire
discussion we've had so so in if I were
to try to summarize it I would I I would
be curious to know if you've heard
enough to where you have some ideas of
how you might want to redraft your draft
oh absolutely I've taken notes on the
comments that we've had here and I must
say
um
I I think that this session has been
extraordinarily useful
um and this subcommittee generally has
performed spectacularly in defining the
issue redefining the issue uh pointing
at direction in which to move I will
spend
um the next 14 days drafting redrafting
re-drafting
sending it to you quietly just for your
review keeping in mind that
if we share information
uh via email including the entire
committee that constitutes public
meeting and that is a public document
just so you know
um but I'll draft it redraft it
um speak to many more people
um and get this to you for our next
meeting
and one is a
that is scheduled for October 31st which
I will expect that we will have a
meeting at that time I would anticipate
that it will not be an extended meeting
and I will expect that all members of
that's why I scare people when I come
out of the elevator so with that we
can't even have a motion to adjourn
because we don't have a quorum but um
I will
um ask for a recess until next time
um and uh thank you profoundly
profoundly thank you uh counselor thank
you Ms Clifford
um you have contributed so significantly
to our thinking today
um not genuinely grateful thanks
foreign